les beaux jours en bord de Loire les
guinguettes rouvrent les unes après les
autres plaisirs de manger ou de se
désaltérer auprès du fleuve rendez-vous
immanquable surtout des amoureux de la
danse à Rochecorbon le lieu est reconnu
dans tout le département y attire les
adeptes du dancefloor rencontre avec
Hélène chapelet
et on est parti pour 5 heures de sport
tout bon sportif le confirmera avant de
faire un effort il faut s'échauffer et
quoi de mieux qu'une petite danse en
ligne pour se dégourdir les jambes et
faire monter le palpiton tout doucement
on peut ensuite enchaîner avec une
musique un peu plus entraînante
[Musique]
nadie François tout de non pas hésité à
faire 45 minutes de route pour venir
participer au lancement de cette
nouvelle saison de La Guinguette de
Rochecorbon une remise en jambes pour ne
rien perdre des cours de danse qu'ils
ont pris pendant une dizaine d'années
pour nous c'est la plus belle de
guinguette de France et vraiment c'est
atypique et il y a toujours une bonne
ambiance on se connaît tous plus ou
moins non c'est vraiment le cadre est
super
et on il y a toujours des bonnes
orchestre aussi
sur la piste Serge et Nicole enchaîne
également les pas de danse leur
spécialité à eux c'est le rock dès
qu'elle rouvre assez de retraités
passent tout leur dimanche après-midi à
la Guinguette de Rochecorbon il faut
dire que c'est sur une piste dedans
qu'ils ont fait connaissance
se rencontrer dans un enseignant
toutes les belles choses qu'on aime et
quand on s'est connu on a dansé le rock
tout l'après-midi on a lancé ensemble
après une courte interruption technique
pour talquer le parquet et le rendre
plus glissant les danseurs ont pu
réintégrer la piste elle était dansant
vont se poursuivre jusqu'au 24 septembre
rendez-vous à La Guinguette de
Rochecorbon tous les jeudis dimanche et
jours fériés de 15 à 20h
[Musique]